uh
elliot kipchoge of kenya as you
mentioned
ran a one hour 59 minute 40 second
marathon but he had like you said the
prototype shoes and he had the
the pace setters yeah i don't know how
essential that is
but it seems quite essential do you
think it's possible
first of all what do you think about
that accomplishment uh
and he is one of the greatest if not the
greatest marathon runners of all time
what do you think about that
accomplishment and do you think it's
possible to run a two-hour marathon
without any assistance yeah i mean i
think yeah there's no question about it
regardless of technology he's
world class if not the best um the
i think he i think he could go under two
or someone equivalent to him could go
under two hours
with with the shoe technology
probably what it'll take is it'll take a
fast course
a course that has like very few tangents
because like
you know turning on a course they
estimate adds about a percent to the
to the distance so you know when we're
talking about a marathon
you're getting up to like a quarter mile
extra running you know that alone could
potentially put you down near
near too flat based on what you know
we're seeing because
i mean kipchichi's got a was it 20140 i
believe
is his actual world record where it's
actually like you know certified
so i mean he's right on the door
knocking knocking on the door there
um yeah the prototype he had since then
they put in a regulation where you can't
stack a shoe for the roads more than 40
millimeters
so you can only have so much of that
energy returning foam and you can only
have i think one
carbon plate in there now uh so
that puts a little bit of a ceiling on
that technological thing
uh but but who knows what else will come
out and that and
and to be honest who comes out with it
because
the fact that nike came out with this
technology is the reason why
it's being allowed to be be used if it
would have been like
you know another running company that
that came out with it i'm sure the
the the regulations would have been
slapped down on it immediately and they
would have probably just thrown it out
altogether would have been
this politics yeah oh yeah well and i
mean it's it
you can go you can go super like
you know negative with that and say like
hey like this is
like this is terrible or this is like
super nefarious when in reality it's
like
you know you have a company that has you
know billions of dollars
and is interested enough in the sport
that otherwise doesn't generate a ton of
revenue
to you know pick up a big tab and
support like uh you know track and field
and things like that
but you know with that you know you if
you want to be the guy who says yeah
thanks for the millions and millions of
dollars but
we're gonna st all those years and money
you spent on that foam
yeah you wasted it we're not gonna let
you use it but you know if you're
another company who
uh you know revolutionizes the sport in
potentially a negative way
uh you know maybe maybe you say no to
them
so it gets interesting that's the way
that's how it always happens yeah yeah
yeah
there's really no way around i think
phil methatone i think it's him that he
wrote a book about a two hour marathon
what are the limits how fast could we
run and i think he puts it like an hour
and 42 minutes something like that or 40
something minutes
it's kind of an interesting question of
what are the limits
do you think do you think we'll just
keep pushing the limits of what humans
are capable of
in the ultras in the marathon is this
just like the way
yeah the uh the way of sport and i think
ultra for sure because that is a fastly
growing
sport and it's there's
there's a lot of potential for much
bigger pop or a much
pool bigger pool of like talent to pull
from
uh that could really push the needle
down on some of these performances and
things like that
uh especially as it becomes more popular
if people start realizing
or i shouldn't say realizing but if a
scenario happens where like oh
i'm one of the best endurance athletes
in the world i make more money running
ultra marathons than i do running the
marathon
then you know all of a sudden we see
every record get broken in a matter of a
couple of years
uh but the the
for the marathon i mean it's going to
get faster i think but
like to what degree is so hard to know
it's very hard to know and that's the
one hour and 40 minutes seems like
that's pretty fast
yes that's very fast for folks for some
perspective there the current world
record
is like in the 440s per mile a mile like
just to add a little flavor to that
you're basically sprinting yeah i mean
go out to a track and run one lap
as fast as you can and then reflect on
what time you get
and realize like the world record for
the marathon is
that is that lap at just over
70 seconds per lap so minute and 10 just
over that
but you're doing it 26.2 miles so
so over a hundred times it's
mind-boggling but watching elliot
kipchoge just first of all he was like
smiling at the end of it
so the there's an extreme efficiency
here too so he's not
he's able to just find the right way to
maximize yeah maximize efficiency it
makes it look
easy i mean that that's true for
basically every olympic athlete
when you watch gymnasts they kind of
make it look easy
yes but there's like tens if not
hundreds of thousands of hours
behind that training yeah just to be
comfortable enough to even attempt some
of the moves they do in gymnastics is
mind-boggling
that one is super awesome because uh how
tragic it is like one little slip
up four years of work and your room it's
all gone
not just four years at work for many of
them like it's like a lifetime of work
and they're teenagers and they're
teenagers and they get dedicated
everything
to it that's that's what makes the
pursuits of humans so fascinating
you